[Music]
eli is with us in chicago hi eli welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you and chris doing
great man how can we help
man you know what i hope you guys have
more than a minute to talk because i got
a phone to pick with you too
i'm in a mess because i i followed your
baby steps
like you said i was able to buy my house
cash
and then i sold some of my real estate
properties and i have five hundred
thousand dollars now
in cash and i don't know what to do with
it and this is all your
you and chris fault yeah i hate it when
this happens
eli i apologize buddy i apologize
i and by the way right off the bat i
want to say i watched your
show last night it was phenomenal chris
i love when you pick on your kids
yes thank you thank you thank you all
right so
do you have any rentals left do you have
any debt left at all
so so no i'm 37 years old and
i'm gonna get a pension with the city i
work with the city here in chicago
um like i said my house is worth about
four hundred thousand i paid it off uh
in cash
um i have five hundred thousand dollars
i'm trying to figure out if i'm why did
you show the room behind
so so in chicago i just i'm i'm so busy
with my job and my dad
uh passed away recently so i've been
helping my mom out a lot so i didn't
want to overwhelm myself
so so i just that's have to so i saved
up all that
you know cash that i had bought a house
for my wife and i and then
anything i had over with the real estate
like i have it sitting but
i don't have anything uh saved for
retirement those were supposed to be my
retirement the building
so now i'm trying to see if i'm am i
ahead or at 37 years old or american
a little bit because i won't you're
you're almost you either are or you're
almost a millionaire yes
so okay so you're ahead you're a 37 year
old everyday millionaire
okay so the question is this you don't
want to buy more real estate because
it's too much hassle because you have so
many things going on right
is that right yeah okay then i
only do two things with money eli and so
i and i don't ever reckon
i don't tell people to do stuff i'm not
willing to do so i don't get fancy with
it one of the things i discovered when i
first started talking to rich people
after i went broke 30 years ago
was the stuff they do is think they put
money in things they understand
and they are not concerned about you
being impressed with their
sophistication
they put money in stuff they know
something about
that's right and i don't put and they're
most of their you know most these guys
that have
anywhere from a 1 million to a 20
million
net worth they are not fancy no
with their investing it's very pretty
straightforward
and we found that again when we surveyed
all these millionaires in the one to
five million
dollar range in particular that's right
so what i'm going to tell you is mutual
funds since you don't want to do real
estate i only do mutual funds in real
estate that's all i do
and so if i woke up and i was in your
shoes and right now i didn't want to
screw with real estate i just need to
get some money working for me
i'd put it in mutual funds across the
four types we talk about without a doubt
and eli i'm proud of you for making the
sacrifice
to be able to free you up to be able to
help your mom i'm sorry to hear about
your dad passing
yeah but you're right when you get when
you make a priorities you make decisions
you make sacrifices to match them
and that's what you've done and so my
friend i'm going to tell you something
don't overthink this
get connected with the smart vista pro
at 37 years old you are an everyday
millionaire
let's grow this money be intentional
about what you're doing but here's the
thing you're gonna have to do
here's the word that's gonna be the the
difference between if you become
a multi-millionaire or not and that is
playing defense
you've got to be smart and go cash only
and if you want a truck save up and buy
a truck you want a boat
well don't buy a boat but just be smart
be intentional
uh but don't don't don't go backward for
debt for any reason
at all and you're gonna be on a great
path see if you take 500 and it's
invested in mutual funds and they make
10 to 12 percent
it's roughly gonna double every seven
years you're 37 at 44 it'll be a million
yeah at 51 it'll be 2 million
at 58 it'll be 4 million
i think you're gonna be okay he's gonna
be okay if that's all you do
that's what i mean by not fancy right
you know you're not constantly screwing
with it you're not going oh it's out
it's out of sync oh there's a problem if
you just put it in there
and set it and forget it look at it you
watch it obviously but i'm saying you
don't have to constantly be
like every day fretting over where where
this mutual fund is and all that get it
up
if it does what the if it does what the
market has done
over its history right that's roughly
what's going to happen is every seven
years or so it's going to double
and that's if you don't add anything to
it right and if you don't take anything
out that's right well that's what i was
saying about not doing stupid and
staying allergic to debt
uh because the thing we know about debt
is that it's needy and greedy
right it's needy and angry he's away
from that he's
on him he's done he's gonna go backwards
he's done yeah just don't
don't stupid uh sneak up ride up on you
it'll sneak up on sounds like a good
deal
it ain't yeah just and that that you
know when that happens is what i was
addressing earlier for folks is
there's something there's this allure
that if it's not
complicated or uber sophisticated it
must not be good yeah
like like we think the rich really do
know secrets we don't know or something
and they really don't all they did was
what you already know they just did it a
lot it's boring
and they do it consistently that
consistency